[Music]
good morning my name is rocky Taylor
I've been a stunt man for 54 years as
I've started around 1961 yes I'm the
hottest working stuntman us both I was
the youngest
now I'm the oldest
[Music]
the source fell into it a third fall
about and do what the actors couldn't do
ie get punched for over a chair diving
rolled along the ground my first stunt
job was a film called The Young Ones
with Sir Cliff Richard they gave me a
Guinness record I've got it over there
the oldest still working stuntmen in
England the only stuntman to doubles for
two buttons in one year Roger Moore the
name is bond in Sean Connery my last
film was this Sunday I was working on a
little car chase sequence around - Fargo
square which was great I mean I've been
in it for so many years now and I can't
think of anything else happening dude
[Music]
I had a very bad action on deaf restrict
I need to go guilt this is the this shot
of me doing the fall which nearly took
my life when they blew it out before I
got to the edge I'll run through the
flames put my hands up over my eyes came
through broke my back pelvis
thank God I survived I don't know how I
survived but you're gonna get a little
knock and a little proof that's part of
the job why do I keep doing it I've had
a great life I've been around the world
twice I've met all the stars
I love it there's nothing else about it
you
[Music]
the paper airplane you folded in middle
school horrible design but I've thrown a
paper airplane 214 feet I'm John Collins
I am the paper airplane guy world record
holder for a paper aircraft distance for
the year we got the record was 2012 it
was you know one of the great days in my
life actually you know I look back at my
child being born in the world record
those are great moments for me I named
the world record plane after my wife the
name of the design is Suzanne this is
how you fold Suzanne you start with the
short side of the paper out on the page
and put it against the right now when
you want to know that you've got an
accent after that is to take all right
right down to the top of the plane you
fold the plane in half it's just eight
simple folds there are a lot of
different kinds of folding techniques
and a lot of different kinds of paper
airplane there's planes that boomerang
back there are planes that are made to
fly straight very far there are planes
that are made of stay in the air for a
long time every great paper airplane
distance or time aloft has very accurate
fully most people want to know how I got
into paper airplanes and the reality is
I never got out of them I am curious by
nature I love math and science the cool
thing about paper airplanes is it's a
way to actually discover something real
about flight what most people don't know
is that we don't know the exact cause
and effect for lift every little paper
airplane throw is like a little science
experiment here's the laboratory right
here in your hand that you could use to
do real science teachers kind of don't
like kids to do paper airplanes it has
this bad-boy kind of renegade reputation
if they could discover that paper
airplanes actually are science that
they're doing science and having fun to
it I think that's an incredible
breakthrough paper airplane throwing
class yes
I am Ernestine shepherd 80 years of age
i benchpress 110 pounds I started
training at age 71 I was named the
oldest female competitive bodybuilder at
the Guinness Book of World Records my
sister and I started exercising together
I had never done any type of exercising
before before she died she said promise
me you will follow my dream and try to
get in the Guinness Book of World
Records so that's what I did
[Music]
I have been in six or seven competitions
I win but some I come out second and
third and I'm pleased with that
[Music]
I'm up every morning at 2:30 after I
have my devotions I walk in I run
approximately ten miles I'm at the gym
at 7:30 and I have a group of ladies
that I trained
I trained all ages one of the youngest I
think she's about 20 years of age and
the rest go from 40 all the way up to 80
when people come to my class for the
very first time they are really really
surprised they said I didn't think this
exercise would be this tough but if you
can do it we are going to do it too
I really don't feel as though I'm 80
years of age but I am I want to keep
training until my day is done when
you're on the trail that long you don't
really think about how long is it gonna
take me to get to somewhere or how fast
am I going you're thinking about don't
get yourself hurt
my name is Karl Meltzer and I am an
ultra-marathoner we did 36 miles
it was pretty weekday but no one's ever
been this far in ten days I just
recently broke the Appalachian Trail
record from Maine to Georgia at 2000 189
miles and I completed that in 45 days 22
hours and 38 minutes beating the
previous record by just a little under
10 hours total mileage average per day
for that 46 days will be forty seven
point six the 80 is not a walk in the
park it's a hard trail every time I clip
my foot and it goes forward it totally
stresses bread ice cream indeed you
really have to have a team it's not just
the one guy running it's really the crew
who if they're not perfect for you then
it really won't be successful I think
Appalachian Trail not only is it very
popular and iconic but it's also very
difficult now it's all downhill and easy
I am concentrating on my foot placement
all the time so two hours goes by awake
enough just because I'm zoned I'm sowing
doubt I slammed my head into the ground
a number of times and it beats you down
you have to expect that but you can beat
it too as long as you just keep
persevering and fighting through the
issues that you're going to have the
last day I ran 85 miles my body was so
amped and ready to be done that it
didn't matter really how far it was I
felt the same in my lady as I did a
mouth and my just numb at that point
really bonus it's important for people
to know the 80 is a special place and it
should be protected it's a trail for one
who wants to gain fellowship with nature
no matter whether you're running it
whether you're walking it whether you're
taking ten years to do it when you walk
that trail you have a vibe and you feel
it every year someone else's gets a
little bit faster someone will break my
record for sure
it might come this year I don't know I'm
still gonna be happy because I gave it
everything I had you know I think that's
what's important
you
[Music]
other few would laugh at me in fact all
my friends say we worry about you
jealous you know
and they even coming up this weekend
somebody said oh now be careful I think
that's ridiculous what a better way to
die having fun I am a world record
holder for being the oldest woman
skydiver
in the world I think is there's only one
way it's down so either if I got slight
absent-mindedness I'll be alright
I don't worry that my carpets is rather
threadbare and old as long as I was guy
diving but I do get scared I've I used
to be so scared that I would drive the
car up to the drop zone and think I
could go back I don't have to stay here
but I knew if I went away I'd never come
back again
so the the the ecstasy was more than the
fear the first time I jumped up an
aeroplane I thought I was really dying
and as I fell I thought what a mistake
this is death I just remember it now and
then the next second I thought ah I'm
flying
[Music]
skydiving gives you the most intense
wonderful feeling
I mean people come down from the sand
and jump and they all say is better than
sex I will take that the way you like it
but it is
[Music]
I think sometimes we get pulled out by
fear we get pulled down by necessity of
work and it's a mistake but having done
skydive I learned courage I learned to
go and that has been the biggest turning
point in my life and I think the courage
has helped me to run a charity which
from scratch
is very difficult I they say most
charities fail after three years and I
knew that I had a program that affected
for the good they profoundly disabled
people made them really much happier and
that thrills me I believe we all have a
purpose in life and I believe that
extras is my purpose
I don't have much time to think about
the past I'm so busy in the present and
just going into the future that the past
recedes and I am enjoying so much these
days
remembering the past remembering even
the difficult times but seeing how they
all fell into a pattern which now I'm
glad of you're a bird for 50 seconds and
imagine you can go 240 miles an hour you
can do a barrel roll you can flick you
can move here you can move there you can
join up with people it is unbelievably
wonderful I won't stop till I know it's
not safe
but for now I'm safe and I can do it and
I will do it for as long as I can
you
[Music]
you
[Music]